When you go to the North Restaurant
Have you tried it?
Order a beef pie
Served with a bowl of millet porridge
Wow delicious
That bowl of millet is not only
a sacred crop
for our Taiwanese aborigines
Better nourishment for the body
Many fans are concerned
Can diabetics eat millet porridge?
Will it cause blood sugar to spike?
In fact, after eating
OOO
Not only can you eat millet porridge with confidence
your blood sugar level can also be stable.
Hu Naiwen starts his lecture
I'm your old friend, Dr. Hu.
I want to share with you today
Eat millet to fight three highs
Aids sleep, nourishes the kidneys, strengthens the spleen and stomach
Eating millet for 3 consecutive months
can effectively fight against the three highs
You must remember this sentence
Have a bowl of millet porridge for breakfast
It's not about health or unhealthy issues
It's the cheapest meal
you'll have all day.
Although millet looks very inconspicuous
But it
has three great effects
Lowering blood sugar
Cholesterol lowering
Stabilize blood pressure
It is a treasure against the three highs
Let me first talk about lowering blood sugar.
According to the Journal of Clinical Nutrition
The study found that it said
Diabetics eat millet
More than three months
Whether on an empty stomach or after a meal
Decreased blood sugar levels
Even the glycated hemoglobin is close to normal
Isn't it great?
I often recommend to diabetics
Add millet to your daily diet
It is gluten-free and easy to digest
Good spleen and stomach absorption
The body is naturally stronger
Nutrition
Helps keep blood sugar stable
Come on
People with diabetes are afraid of eating porridge
Right?
Are you afraid of millet porridge?
Afraid
Most afraid
Blood sugar spike
Don't be afraid
When you eat porridge or millet porridge
Cantonese porridge seafood porridge
To match one thing
That is to do exercise
What exercises to do
You can brisk walk or slow jogging
Eating porridge can increase blood sugar levels quickly
The speed of lowering blood sugar is also fast
Exercise will make it easier
to stabilize your blood sugar.
The cholesterol-lowering effect of millet
How great is it
Millet contains more dietary fiber
and unsaturated fatty acids
Millet can
clear blood vessels
Can prevent constipation
Can reduce the risk of arteriosclerosis
Make your heart stronger
Millet is high
in potassium and magnesium
These two nutrients
are important for blood pressure
Potassium can remove
excess salt from the body
Reduce the burden
of salt on blood pressure
What are the benefits of magnesium?
It can relax tense blood vessels
This will naturally lower your blood pressure.
Do you feel heavy due to poor sleep?
1 bowl of millet porridge to fall asleep quickly
At noon when the sun was at its highest, farmers were still working hard in the fields, turning the soil and weeding with hoes.
It's really hard work
When you feel
that life is not going well
Don't panic, don't sleep poorly
Check your wallet and deposits
Just cry
Don't cry for too long
At this time,
you must drink a bowl of millet porridge
Sleep well
Love the people around you well
Will love disappear?
I don't know
But I know
If you don't take care of your health
you will disappear.
Millet porridge strengthens the spleen and removes shī qì(transliteration)
The most nourishing thing is the rice oil
on the millet porridge
Stomach is uncomfortable, after surgery.
Or mothers in northern China give birth
will drink a bowl of millet porridge
It nourishes you as effectively as ginseng
Therefore, it is also called
dài cān tāng(transliteration)
Instead of ginseng
Do you always have trouble sleeping at night?
Millet contains tryptophan
It is very rich in content
7 times more than white rice
Per 100 grams of millet
have 160 mg of tryptophan
White rice only has 22 mg
Look at how different it is.
Tryptophan can help you
stabilize your nerves
Let you sleep as soundly as a baby
People who always need to take sleeping pills
to sleep
You can eat millet porridge instead
The effect is really good
Drink millet porridge regularly
What changes will occur in the body
You will find
The body feels good
Persist in drinking for one year.
Not only metabolism improves
Even my complexion, sleep quality and spirit
have been greatly improved
I recently had a patient
He told me
Because of my previous show
He eats millet porridge
As a result, his stomach
was healed.
So he a few days ago
Also gave me a special pack
of millet
He said there are only one or two places
in Taiwan where you can buy it.
Hot and cold weather
Millet plus it tastes best.
Don't despise the person who has always been with you
Don't stay with someone who always dislikes you
3 ways to eat millet
Accompany you from spring to summer and autumn to winter
Ways to cool down in hot weather
and warm up in cold weather
Hey, that's great.
High temperatures in spring and summer
Millet and mung beans cooked
Cook into mung bean and millet porridge
Mung beans clear away heat and detoxify
Millet strengthens the spleen and stomach
It can also be diuretic
can remove the rè(transliteration)
Take a sip
As if a cool breeze blew
The Shǔ qì(transliteration) is gone
Mm, super cooling
Temperatures drop in autumn and winter
hands and feet are also cold
waist and back hurt.
All those little problems
came out
At this time
eat a bowl of warm yam lean meat millet porridge
Compendium of Materia Medica says millet
is the grain of the kidney.
Millet nourishes the kidneys, spleen and stomach
Yam nourishes the lungs and kidneys
They put together
spleen, stomach, lungs, and kidneys
All made up for you
All filled up
Make the body stronger
Complexion is better
Isn't it awesome?
People with kidney deficiency will have back pain
Cold hands and feet, frequent urination
People with kidney heat will have yellow urine
Symptoms of restlessness
and insomnia
Let's eat yam and lean meat millet porridge
Drink it in one gulp to warm and nourish the kidney qi
Not only the hands and feet are warm
heart is warmed
Make you full of energy
Have energy all day
Those who love sweet food must try it
Pumpkin Millet Porridge
It is especially good for people
with stomach discomfort.
Pumpkin pectin
Can protect the stomach lining
Gastrointestinal mucosa
Reduce ulcers
Smoother digestion
There is a saying
People are eating buns
You're shouting hot there
suggest you eat the porridge
while it's hot.
There is a saying from the ancients:
Níng rén děng zhōu wú zhōu děng rén (transliteration)
What do it mean?
would rather wait for the porridge to be cooked before eating.
Don't let the porridge cool down before eating
Why?
Because a bowl of hot porridge
The entrance is the most warm and nourishing state
It can nourish the spleen and stomach
This is the best millet porridge to choose
Add 1 thing and it won't be bitter.
How to cook millet porridge to make it delicious
Tell you secretly
My beautiful wife always cooks millet porridge
with glutinous millet
The texture after cooking
is QQ and sticky.
Every grain of rice slowly melts
in your mouth
Wow, very good
Two common types of millet
Glutinous millet foxtail millet
Taiwan's native millet
Most of them are glutinous millet
And what about those imported from abroad?
The most common one is the foxtail millet
Let’s first talk about the characteristics of glutinous millet
It is well cooked and soft
Cook into porridge thick and smooth
We Taiwanese aborigines use glutinous millet
to cook rice
porridge and even make millet wine.
What about people who have poor physical strength
get tired easily, or have just had surgery or a serious illness?
Eating glutinous millet replenishes qi and benefits qi
And it helps you to moisten your intestines and have a bowel movement
The second type is foxtail millet
The taste is relatively hard
It won't get mushy easily after being cooked for a long time
Tastes relatively refreshing
Blood sugar easily goes up and down
Body constitution tends to be damp and heavy
Or people with edema
Suitable for eating foxtail millet
foxtail millet can
Strengthens the spleen, removes dampness, clears heat and calms the mind
It can also stabilize blood sugar
A fan asked me
How to cook millet porridge
It won't be bitter
Hey, I have a bonus for you.
You cook millet and white rice together to make porridge
It won't taste bitter.
Northern Chinese
They often add a little oatmeal
to the millet porridge
when they cook it.
Turn into millet oatmeal porridge
The porridge cooked this way
tastes smoother.
And slow down the rate of blood sugar rise
It's great for grandparents,
and diabetics can eat it
with peace of mind
There are also some tips for eating millet
Caution required
These two types of people should not eat too much millet
The first type is people who urinate more
The second type is people with a weak and cold constitution
Because millet has a diuretic effect
If you have a lot of urine,
you can eat millet porridge
but don't eat too many bowls.
Don't eat too much before bed.
Otherwise, wanted to drink millet porridge
to help sleep.
But kept going to the toilet
Going to the toilet all the time
You won't get the health benefits
you want.
It is recommended to drink in moderation
The second is
People with a weak constitution
Not recommended either
You eat too much millet
People with weak constitutions are prone to cold hands and feet
in winter.
Loose stools
Eat more millet porridge
It will make the body colder
Instead, feel uncomfortable
So this type of people eat millet porridge
Can be served with warm food
Or eat a small amount
Only then can we truly nourish the spleen and warm the stomach
Millet went from a food of the poor
to an international superstar
Aboriginal friends
Do you like to drink millet wine the most?
Right?
You are really wise.
Make millet into millet wine
Did you know
Four or five thousand years ago
Neolithic sites in northern China
There is evidence that millet is used to make wine.
Starting from the Xia and Shang dynasties
Millet is the staple food of northerners.
In the past, millet was called "Su"(transliteration) in China.
"Su"(transliteration) culture was passed down from ancient times to the Song, Liao and Jin dynasties.
Even now in the north of the mainland
Mother gives birth to a child
After the mother gave birth
Even now in the northern part of the mainland
After the mother gives birth
also drink millet porridge to nourish my body.
You think China is the kingdom of millet production
Humph, no
India is
The world's largest millet producer
Not only can cook porridge
Others also make big pancakes and thin pancakes
Cooked with lentils for a delicious meal
heard that even in 2018
The Indian government announced that the year would be the year
of millet in the country.
and proposed to the United Nations
Designate 2023 as the
International Year of Millet
Finally passed
Ha ha
Millet is awesome!
Dear fans,
We have opened the membership channel
If you agree with Dr. Hu's promotion of Chinese medicine
The concept of taking care of your own health
Small monthly donations are welcome
Or become a VIP sponsor
With you
We can go further
Thank you so much